this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio
this is the ramsey show it's where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about
your life your money your work
your relationships we're talking life it
all plays together
i am ken coleman joined by my colleague
john deloney
and we are taking you through this hour
of the ramsay show triple eight eight
two five
five two two five is the phone number
it's a free
call triple eight eight two five five
two two five and john we've got a full
lobby here at ramsey solutions
some fantastic people out there we've
got some debt free screams coming up
we got a teacher interview coming up we
got people calling to get clarity
coming up and uh it's always fun to be
with you my friend
thanks man you too looking forward to it
it's good to see everyone out there yeah
yeah great great group by the way great
reminder we are open
if you want to come to nashville and uh
the area and come a little south here in
franklin
uh check us out ramseysolutions.com let
us know you're coming we've got
uh free baked goods coffee you got your
iced coffees you got your
i don't know do they have any juice over
there yes they got the juice yes they
got it
yeah i got the juice do you but that's
because i'm passionate about what i do
that's what we say on the ken coleman
show when you're living on purpose and
working on purpose
you got the juice i see in the it's not
just a j-o-b john in the health and
wellness industry the juice
steroids so it's cool man well i think
anybody that's watching on youtube right
now can take a quick
gander at me and quickly certainly
i mean i don't think i'm gonna shock
anybody with that statement if you hang
on till hour three today good folks
kid and i are gonna do push-ups push-ups
that's right you know
this desk is big enough for me to get on
that end
and i i'm short and i don't think hits
you if we go head-to-head
uh during the commercial break maybe
we'll get that kelly's not sure kelly's
long enough but my self-esteem is not
quite that long it's it's
yeah i couldn't do it i could do that
could you yeah i have no problem
knocking out some push-ups all right
but we're not gonna say that for the
next segment all right triple eight
eight two five five two two five we're
gonna have a blast today you know why
because we're gonna be diving in with
you whether it's talking about your
relationships
toxicity at work hey am i doing what i
love how do i make more money what do i
do with my budget how do i get out of
debt
this is all going somewhere that really
really matters and that's why this is
going to be fun let's go to tallahassee
florida to start it off
chris joins us there chris you're on the
ramsay show
hey guys how's it going appreciate you
having me we're having a blast what's up
hey um quick question for you guys so
i'm you know going through baby steps we
were on the latter end of that
um so i got a structure to set on my
co-payment coming up um this february
and uh he's got 50 000 coming in and
looking to see
if i need to just send that you know max
out the roth ira that
that year and then put the rest and i
got a son um
put into his 529 kind of max that out
and then put the rest towards the house
or how would you guys kind of split that
up
sounds like you're following the baby
steps is that true
yep so one well baby step are step
uh so this is going into four and five
kind of a hybrid there um
so we've got about with an employer
match got about 12 percent going into
the
retirement um so what's the settlement
from
um so i had a motorcycle accident um
about 10 years ago now
um so we got a payment this february and
then i got a couple others
um in five year batches out until i'm uh
until i'm 40. okay
yeah well i mean you know the baby steps
and so you know i think your question is
spot on but that's what you do
you allow you you take this settlement
and you plug it into the baby steps
okay yeah would you suggest going more
so
more towards the house early on and kind
of just
the 529 is rolling um and will be you
know
primed up and paid up by the time i send
goes to college
would you suggest putting more towards
the house
how much well let's play the numbers how
much do you mind telling us how much a
settlement is
fifty thousand 000 coming on this wave
and i got a hundred thousand
on the ladder too okay so 150 total
correct or no 250. oh okay all right all
right so
250. so how much uh would you need to
put into the 529
i understand it's rolling um it's but
what's the difference right now like how
much of that would get him to
that number that you want for the
college fund
so it's probably going to be about 45
we'll just pay it up and kind of get
that flat baseline
and then obviously the quicker you get
it paid up you know it can accrue
you know tax-free interest yeah um how
much do you own
128 on it right now yeah i i would
finish out the college fund
uh because that's gonna accrue now
you've knocked that step out completely
and so the money you were putting into
that
now we start putting that towards the
house and then the rest of the money
that
just so it's the same idea as the
debt-free snowball here
and so you just take that money finish
out the college fund step that's there
now it's fully funded and it's going and
now we re
we take those funds and we knock out as
much of the house as you can and
with the understanding that no matter
what your employment status is in five
years you can get a hundred thousand
dollar
and it's check and that's you know the
idea with all these steps is obviously
to avoid
having any any type of fallback or
anything like that well yeah but by the
you you really are running as fast as
you can towards paying your house off
yeah
knowing that regardless of where you are
in five years that's gonna be what pays
your house off right so
i would front load those yeah front load
your accounts on the front end here yeah
because you've got a five year you're
gonna be completely debt free
completely paid up on your on your uh
529 you're gonna be where you need to be
in five years regardless yeah
um so man yeah the earlier you can get
that stuff accruing interest
yeah so just knock it the answer is
knock out four and five yeah
so knock them out and follow them and
you're going to be fine you
you don't need you've got a backup plan
i mean just think about that just the
money he's going to put in his house if
you fill a hard time you sell the house
yeah there's so much equity in it
and then you're debt free on on six
anyway so yeah just follow it out don't
overthink it and i think
to speak to that what's the what's the
psychology there of a guy who again
he's just like me just like everybody
else he's walking this stuff out he's in
great financial shape this settlement is
only going to make it better
but yet there's still fear should i
spend this money
we struggle so much with just how s
little we control in the world yeah how
simple life is when we just
play it out yeah right when we if we can
just put our head in
the mind of the tortoise and just take
little steps one after the other and so
yeah it's 50 000 come on
just follow the plan man and it feels
like we're not doing enough it feels
like well i gotta be doing more and this
is a bit
just keep following that plan and can i
can't tell you how many times i've tried
to
short-circuit it hey i'll just do double
the workouts today
yeah and that'll get me double the in
shape tomorrow it just makes me so sore
you can't move right yeah
so i'm i'm not the licensed psychologist
i don't have the training you do but
when i'm talking to people like this on
the ken coleman show and we get a
question like this i'm gonna go okay
let's just lay this out
what's the fear name the thing you're
afraid of well i lose my job can
i i think that's important would you
agree with that
so it's really you know i'm not going to
make chris do that because chris is in
great shape but it's almost like
chris and if anybody's like chris what
are you really scared of what's the name
the way i say it is write it down i love
it and then demand evidence from it yeah
are you
seriously yeah the worst mom oh we said
this yeah
are you put it on the witness stand yep
you're not
right are you really too overweight for
someone to love you no you're not
i love you are you seriously gonna be
broke in five years
by following baby steps yeah no you're
not yeah most of the time if you demand
evidence from your fears
you realize you've been lying to
yourself right right
and then accept the truth and focus on
the truth
hey i got this we're gonna do this take
a deep breath
and keep on moving let me tell you what
we're gonna do we're gonna keep on
broadcasting
life-changing radio don't move this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more
firsts
[Music]
welcome back america you have joined the
conversation here on the ramsay show i'm
ken coleman joined with my colleague
john dalone we're taking your questions
about your life
your work your relationships and
we are here for you i just feel like
somebody needs to call today you're
going i've thought about it before
i think today's the day well let's go
triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five
two two five well it's april john and
you know around here that's a big big
month for ramsey solutions because
it's national financial literacy month
and with all of our involvement with
ramsey ed
ramsey education solutions in america
schools
we do our teacher appreciation giveaway
it's sponsored by mint mobile
the affordable premium wireless provider
and because of the dedicated teachers
across the country our foundations
in personal finance curriculum is
teaching students how to save avoid debt
and pay cash for things like cars and
college
it's changing family trees helping kids
not maybe make the mistakes that their
parents and grandparents made
and we love these testimonies so
teachers
anybody listening if you're a teacher we
want you to enter today for a chance to
win some awesome prizes
like five thousand dollars in
cash you can use that however you like
go to ramseysolutions.com
teacher that's ramsey solutions.com
teacher and you've got to enter by april
the 30th if you're not a teacher
share this with a teacher
in your life and one of the things we
love to do here on the ramsay show
is highlight the unbelievable
impact that the teachers who engage with
us uh
and teach foundations and personal
finance in their school
and and the impact they make and so we
are going to go to
uh amanda who joins us on the line
uh she is at temple high school in the
atlanta georgia
area amanda you're on the ramsay show
hi guys thanks for talking with me
what's
whereabouts in the atlanta areas temple
high school well we're not really
in atlanta it's temple georgia but we're
really close we're about
if you go i-20 west we're about 40
minutes outside oh yeah
yeah sure sure i got you all right very
good and uh this is a public school i'm
looking here with 627
kids enrolled and you've been a teacher
for how many years
this is my 14th year wow and how long
have you been teaching
foundations in uh personal finance eight
wow so how did you come across
dave ramsey or our curriculum
yeah so i'm kind of a lifer i'm kind of
a fan girl for dave
and john it's good to talk to you
because i had the pleasure of talking
with you last week on your show it
hasn't aired yet but i'm excited to hear
that back
yeah it's great to talk to you i first
went through spu as a college kid and
then my husband
and i took it again in fact we missed
our very first week of class on our
honeymoon
so like the second we got married we
went through it again
and i've led nine fpu classes i think
now to the church
and it's just so exciting to bring this
content to the high school kids
so fun so when you first brought it to
the school what was that like getting it
started take it to the early days
eight years ago of beginning this
process of teaching this
yeah well i kind of get to start over
again this is my first year at temple
so i brought it with me when i came over
and it's been
so exciting to share this with these
kids because we had financial literacy
here but it wasn't the ramsay content
and just
the the content just makes it so
relatable
and easy to grasp ideas
that are so counter cultural to what
they're being told
you know i've had tons of parents react
in lots of different ways some are
excited and they're emailing me saying
hey send me your tax information stuff
because i'm about to do my taxes and
and i want to make sure i'm doing a ride
or or you know send me the the chapter
you taught on budgeting like can i talk
to you about that but then i've also had
parents at a previous
system that said i don't know what
you're teaching my kid but i don't want
them to be in your cult
you know so i mean it's kind of you know
it's very
different you know having to to approach
the kids with
with these ideas and knowing that
they're so different than
what they're hearing at home yeah that's
fantastic so
penis paint us a picture of the last
year or two
for the average teacher
um there was a forced giggle if i've
ever heard one
utter chaos to be honest um i i have
several
friends that have left the industry
and and i have several that you know
myself included where i feel like
i'm in my sweet spot even more now than
i was before
you know to use ken's language so um
it's it's weird it's it's hard it's
challenging
we have i teach business and financial
so
you know there are things that covet has
affected positively for our young people
uh as far as the way they approach the
workforce the
the the doors that are now open with you
know virtual working and working from
home and this
is that that i i kind of have a new
curriculum to teach
you know how to do business and finance
in this new world you know when the
banks are closed well how do you do
online thinking you know things like
that
so um it's it's challenging but it's
forced us to be creative sounds like you
are a teacher who's been in the business
that
i used to teach as well at a public high
school and man after one year it's easy
just to say okay i've already got that
lesson done
and i'm just gonna i'm gonna coast and
it sounds like you are
a teacher who's so invested in the
changed outcomes for your in your
students lives
that you are somebody who's constantly
revising constantly trying to find new
things constantly challenging yourself
and that's exhausting and frustrating
and annoying but it's the it's the rich
part of the gig too
absolutely for sure i'm so glad you make
me happy that my kids are
in the community in a public school
because there's teachers like you
millions of you everywhere across the
country doing extraordinary work i'm so
grateful for you you are joining our
conversation with
amanda wilson who is a teacher at temple
high school in temple georgia and she
teaches our
foundations in personal finance
curriculum and we are honoring her for
uh financial literacy month and amanda i
want to ask you
take us to a story that pops up top of
your heart
uh about a kid or maybe multiple kids
that got this stuff and and did
something
really cool with it or they you saw the
change really stick and as a result
some great results yeah well this is the
first year i've been with this group of
students so
the longevity stories i don't really
have a lot of those but what i
am starting to see because i'm still in
the same community as the school i came
from
is that now i've kind of started a side
hustle ministry on i mean i'm not
charging for it but
my previous financial babies would come
back and they're like
okay i just graduated nursing school and
i got a 35 000
bonus what do i do now you know and so
they'll call me and say
hey can i get you coffee can we talk
about my budget or can i
how do i do this and so it's kind of
started a little ministry counseling
thing once a student always a student
and so they know that there's always a
safe place for them to come back and ask
questions and and
get advice and things like that and and
that's what's
so powerful is that i'm i'm teaching
this to adults i'm living this in my
family we're on baby step
six um in fact yesterday my husband and
i paid cash for our dave car
one new car um tell us about that
what kind of car come on we got to brag
a little bit you earned it
well it's modest it's a 2017 ford
explorer but
it's got all the bells and so many
whistles
oh my gosh i didn't know how bad my own
car was i thought it was okay and so i
got in a new one
you know what here's the thing though it
was okay
you made it work that's what i want
people to hear you made it work
uh and it is okay and yet now you're in
a place where you earned it amanda let
me just say on behalf of john and
our entire uh ramsey solutions team
we're proud to be associated with men
and women like you
who are giving of yourself beyond the
classroom you are truly leaving a legacy
so thank you for joining us on the call
thank you for what you do well it's my
pleasure and thank you for all the great
content i look forward to seeing you
guys at summit virtually
hey come on all right that's going to be
a lot of fun
well john i mean that's what it's about
yeah let's not forget
that we did some study here at ramsey
solutions
and the third largest group of net worth
millionaires in the united states
our teacher and after having been a
teacher and
my wife's been a teacher for years they
don't make billionaire money they make
millionaire decisions
great every single day great statement
love that
all right john delaney ken coleman here
with you
on the ramsey show don't move because
i'm looking out in the lobby and i see
ourselves
a great couple who's going to be doing a
debt-free screen don't move we're coming
right back
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switched to puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just thirty dollars a month get
unlimited talk text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over seventy 70
a month
by switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com
and enter the promo code ramsey to save
50
off your first month pure talk simply
smarter wireless
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show america
thrilled to have you with us as we talk
about your life
your work money relationships
how to live to the fullest live like no
one else so that you can give like no
one else
dr john deloney joins me i'm ken coleman
we're ramsey's
ramsey personalities we both have our
own shows the ken coleman show and the
dr john delaney show on
the ramsey network and we're taking you
through this
hour in the lobby of ramsey solutions
world headquarters are jacob and heather
welcome
hello ken hey dr john what's up where
are you guys from
saint louis missouri all right all right
and uh you're here because
you're dead for debt-free that's fun so
let's learn how much you paid off tell
us the number
we paid off 155 and 900
wow and how long did it take you to do
that four years and one month four years
in one month
so you'll ground it down huh yeah yes we
did i love the specificity always of
these stories hey when you go
five years it is just every month counts
exactly right and uh range of income
um so we started around a hundred
thousand um and then we're at about 125
000 now oh nice what'd you do to bump it
up uh
job changes and a lot of overtime yeah
what do you both do i'm a nurse and i'm
a letter carrier for the post office
nice so you you were racking some
overtime as well for the usps
yes i was okay how crazy was it during
uh during the covet
um parcel wise it was really crazy but
other than that it wasn't other than
that all right good now what type of
debt are we talking about
we paid off our mortgage was the only
debt you had
it was the only time we had wow okay so
what happened uh so here we go let's see
four years one month ago
you guys go on this journey how did this
come about um
we bought a we got married and what
every married couple does is they go and
buy a house
it was an impulse buy it was the first
thing i've ever impulse bought
and i immediately felt terrible about it
it was a house
um wow i imposed by like dorito tacos
that's really impressive yeah so we knew
that we needed to get things together
and how long you been married um four
years yeah
okay so you got married bought a house
and then looked at each other went oh no
were you familiar with dave ramsey
ramsay solutions i mean
where did this guilt come from within
moments of walking inside the home
um so when i was little my aunt had a
total money makeover book at her house
but i don't
they never really followed so i kind of
knew the name
but other than that he started listening
right after we bought the house actually
and he started talking to me about the
principles which
made sense um i was always raised if you
don't have cash you don't buy it
and so i mean to us that made sense and
you were already there
yourself you were like i don't like this
155 000 okay yeah
interesting so what was the decision
like
to actually get after this so yeah i
know you made this decision okay we're
going to do this then how did it begin
to change things
what did you start doing um it was
pretty slow to start because
actually of me i had just
cash flowed my second degree and i was
making
decent money for the first time in a
while and i wanted to spend it
i get that yeah so i i was a little slow
to get on board but i thought i'd be a
good wife and if you wanted to do this
we could put a little bit of money each
month and then
then we bought a hot tub yeah we bought
a hot tub
um and then but you paid cash but we
paid cash for the hot tub
i don't want to totally beat yourself up
over there yeah um
if you get a nursing degree you get a
hot tub that's a new dave that's it
that's baby step 4.3 why not
okay all right all right um so i mean
from there
we had pmi and once we paid off that pmi
i really got on board and we actually
ended up putting my entire income
towards that from that point forward wow
yeah cause i was gonna say this is a
tremendous amount here i mean this is
getting with it
i mean was it rice and beans beans and
rice did you go that far
we actually like rice and beans yeah we
uh canceled
we didn't have tv or just but you had a
hot tub
we sold everything that wasn't kneeled
down except for the hot dogs i'm going
to tell you this john
if i've got a hot tub i'm going to be
okay with no tv and rice and beans
because i can at least eat
rice and beans in the house in the hot
tub and then you all had to do weird
married things like
just talk to one another go for walks
and hikes and hang out in the hot tub i
mean
because you weren't just gonna sit there
and scroll mindlessly through some
streaming service right
right so my guess is four years later
after putting in all that sweat equity
and tear equity
your marriage is better too yeah yeah
yeah
we we've definitely come a long way yeah
so talk to other couples what's the key
no matter what their story is what's the
key to getting on board together
and sticking with it
[Music]
i think you have to have a common goal
and if you have a common goal
and it's worth sacrificing for you can
do it if you believe you can do it and
you have that common goal
how old are you two 30 30 30. so now
what
you owe nobody anything
and the mail's not going to stop coming
and people are going to stop going to
hospitals and so
what's next um we'd like to start
working towards self-employment
uh eventually right now we're just gonna
start saving just save
all right this is what i want to hear
because this is what i do i try to help
people
achieve their dreams right get promoted
get that dream job
and work like no one else i want to know
what's the dream there
working for yourself you allow you can
you share that you got you got
you got at least a a fuzzy version of
that dream
um owning i think mainly real estate
real estate well
now you're set up that's stacking money
okay
good that's fantastic talk to us about
your support system along the way when a
couple decides to do this and
and live really differently and take one
person's entire income and put it
towards debt
that's a little strange who is your
support system really
just each other no one really knew we
were on this journey or
really what do you think about that doc
i think these two are gangsters that's
what i think
i it's the quiet ones it's the mail
carrier that's walking around with the
paid off house right
or it's the nurse who smiles a little
bit more because she's got a little less
stress
in her life that's incredible you two
yeah incredible is right
wow unbelievable parents on board your
friends just kind of laugh and make fun
of you
yeah yeah they would pretty much just
say well why would you want to do that
yeah interesting and so tell us about
a heart i mean the last year has been
rough on nurses
really rough everybody gets off a shift
and they're all going to just
what the closest margarita shop there is
and you say
oh i'm going home exactly to sit in my
hot tub and that was the goal have yet
another burrito
what do you say um i mean
i always encourage people to do it and i
think
people don't really understand the value
which is surprising to me
but i think it's worth it yes it
absolutely you two are free
we're free yes four years in you're free
incredible and now moving steadily
towards
dreaming and making those dreams a
reality so good
so good what a great story all right you
guys ready you've been
you've been warming up i'm ready you
look ready get the hands held there we
go look at that couple
folks it is jacob and heather
from st louis missouri they paid off 155
thousand dollars nine hundred fifty five
thousand nine hundred dollars in four
years
and one month making a hundred k
to 125 000
jacob and heather take it away let's
hear your debt free scream
three two one we're debt-free
yes there it is and they
are look at that
look at that young couple that's the
finish line and and that's what we love
about the debt free street it's the
finish line yet it's the starting line
a whole new race right whole new race
and they can walk they can run they can
just head off into the woods they do it
whatever they want they hop off the
trail lay under a tree for a couple days
i don't want to blow by this because i
have a tendency to do this i see
somebody
who buys an makes an impulse purchase
again not everyone impulse buys a house
they did to this debt-free screen
there's digital confetti falling behind
them right all that
in between is four years
of monthly grinding annoyances
frustrations squeezing the last little
bit of lotion out of the tube because we
don't have it in the budget to go get
some more
and you're thinking i make so much money
why don't you do this but you keep going
and keep going and keep going
so so worth it take a little step in a
little step in a little step
in four years you can look up you're
gonna be there do what you have to do
john so that you can do what you want to
do and this applies to money as well
that's why the baby steps work
so great what a great young couple all
right john and i are going to go out and
high five them
congratulate them and then we're coming
right back this is the ramsay show
[Music]
ramsay show continues i'm ken coleman
joined by dr john dolone as we take your
calls
we are a ranch personalities and a part
of the ramsey network
dr john deloney show fabulous show
new episodes every monday wednesday and
friday on
youtube and you can get them anywhere
you listen to podcasts and the ken
coleman show
syndicated on 70 plus stations around
the country siriusxm
and on youtube monday through friday as
well just search the ken coleman show on
youtube
and uh wherever podcasts are available
and so
john uh john you focus on
mental emotional health it's
relationship health i mean just
all across pretty much everything pretty
much everything and i'm focused on
helping people
do what they were created to do simply
put we believe that you were created to
work
now that sounds gross for some of you
when i say created to contribute that
starts to hit a nerve
everybody wants to make a difference
john and it turns out
that some of the stuff you cover and
some of the stuff i cover interconnects
a good bit with toxicity in the
workplace so if you're in a situation
you're going i need my job dude
i'm walking the baby steps but i don't
know if i can hang on any longer
give us a shout give us a shout i would
love that and i want to
ask you something ken so i was reading
something a few weeks ago
and this author she's brilliant she was
talking about and tell me if you see
this on your show
what we used to as a society we used to
have our small little village
and the small little village gave us our
central values it gave us
the the cultural norms what was cool
what's not cool here's how we talked
that
and then it shifted to on a larger scale
our religious communities said here's
here's our
general set of values here's who we talk
how we talk to another whatever
and now we're in this completely
decentralized
universe and we are trying to get
cultural and collective values from our
workplace
and so we are all going to work and
trying to find this sense of purpose and
the sense of value in the sense of what
should i be
dressing and how do we all talk together
and every business has a different
culture and every place and so it's just
decentralizing everything
but it goes back to this idea and i
hadn't thought of it in my head
we are putting a lot into this idea of
work
we're getting a lot of value purpose
meaning this isn't just about earning a
check anymore making sure that
we got food on the table this is about
answering questions like
who am i and what's my role here right
yeah that's new and different it feels
like
no i don't think it is i don't think so
no genesis chapter 2 makes it pretty
clear that
we were created to work that work is
something that we do
um and so i think that that men and
women throughout history have longed to
make a difference in their world
and i i think purpose comes down to two
areas in our life relationally and
professionally
you you cover a relationship i cover the
professional side of things
and what i mean by that is that your
identity and your
value as a human being has nothing to do
with the size of your salary
right or the notoriety
attached to your work but as it relates
to significance
and contributing to the world it matters
deeply
and so when you spend you know if
there's a reason why
torture the the the the evil nazis that
the torture
was to have prisoners move one pile of
rocks
from one side of the prison camp to the
other just futility huh
yeah that's that's that is not a
physical torture there even though
that's hard work
that was an emotional psychological
psychological torture there's no
meaning in what i'm doing and so if you
spend your whole
life 35 40 years doing a job that you
don't have any passion for you don't
love the work itself and the work itself
doesn't create a result that you
connect to then that's then that's the
issue so
in what she's saying if she's saying
look we're putting too much into
our title just that
don't under um don't undersell how
important work is don't understand how
important
cultural fit don't understand how
important we're putting a lot in there
well the reason is is because we long to
make a difference and so
the ramsey solutions world view of work
is that you
were created to work you don't
work to live the secular world view of
where just
the general world view of work is that i
just work to get a paycheck to be able
to cover the basics
and if i'm fortunate enough to make more
than that and i can have some toys
and make some additional memories
awesome but
it's not a utilitarian function that's
not the cause of work
so is it this is i never thought of this
question is it my responsibility to
bring meaning to my job
or vice versa for instance if i
if someone is listening to this and they
are the assistant director of the mail
room
and the large office complex where they
work
they don't make a huge salary but
without them
this business does not operate yeah so
is it their responsibility to say
to find the meeting and what they're
doing well they need it's not a
responsibility it's a reality
okay any job everybody that i'm looking
at on our team
everybody in here their job does matter
well yeah we could just run our mouths
all day nobody's gonna we're nothing
without them
yeah the question is does the job matter
deeply to them
and so that's your responsibility so you
need to understand the reality is is
that a job
does matter somebody needs to do it if
you're doing it but it's okay that it's
not your
ultimate dream job right now it's where
you are and you're working your way up
maybe you're getting out of debt
whatever your situation but ultimately
what we're teaching is and what i
believe is you need to be in a job that
matters deeply to you all the work
matters
but does it matter deeply to you that's
why we talk about talent passion and
mission coming together so let's put it
this way
if a human being spends their whole work
career just doing something they're good
at
they'll be successful okay they'll
deliver results
and get paid probably get promoted if
they
do something they're good at that's
talent and something they love to do
just the work itself there'll be some
deep satisfaction there
but if they do something they're good at
that's talent and they
and they do something they love that's
passion and then
that work that they're doing also
creates results
that fills their heart they go that
matters really deeply to me i like
producing these results there's a
personal connection to these results
that's mission now we're talking about
significance in a person they begin to
see the significance of their
contribution to the world has nothing to
do with success
or satisfaction or even can you have a
mission that is can go from job to job
sure once you land there once you know
your purpose and mission yeah that's
what i teach you stay in your sweet spot
the rest of your life
yeah but you're still moving up yeah and
that and by the way that that kind of
helps some folks
the dream job's not just one thing
by the way it's not just one career it's
who you're going to be wherever you go
are you using your talent to perform
work that you love passion
to produce results that matter deeply to
your mission
so i could see a person go from and i
get this call at the time of the cold
show we could get somebody a teacher
that goes
hey i want to i want to move out of
being an elementary teacher and i want
to go into corporate training
let's just break that down so if you're
talented as a teacher
what are the talents you got to have
does that cross over to being a trainer
yes
the work you love as a teacher is that
work also
something that you love as a trainer yes
that's instruction they love instruction
the research the instructing the guiding
if you will
and then what are the results that
matter to you well if it's teaching and
educating a child or just
mentoring a child or giving a child a
bump yeah but if you're doing that in
the corporate world same thing so
it's like a litmus test of hey as long
as i'm doing
this type of work i know that i'm doing
what i was created to do and therefore
you can do that anywhere anywhere and
it's not about money
you'll make money and you'll have enough
money which is why again teachers are
the third largest group
of net worth millionaires why well
because they're
they they've gone to significance and
satisfaction and success have come along
with it because they had altered their
lifestyle
to fit their mission to fit the mission
you just broke it all down i didn't look
at me well you just interviewed me
but that's the deal there yeah so here's
the deal let's talk about where you come
into this
we get calls when you come on my show
and some of the calls we could take
today folks if you feel like you're in a
toxic workplace you're going i need my
job to get out of the baby steps i need
the shuffle i need the big shovel
i'll talk big shovel with you but we
could talk about that what's that look
like one of the things we fall into
all the time we get these calls i'm
doing something i love but i can't stand
the place i'm doing it and we say it's
doing the right thing in the wrong place
you can be in that sweet spot that we
just had fun talking about
and be in a toxic work environment an
abusive environment co-workers maybe a
leader who's just a toxic leader
and you can hate going in everything you
want to talk about confusion yeah
that's confusion absolutely and there's
no need so let's help you get clear
we'll take those calls and take your
money calls john
ben fun hour our producer ben hill our
associates at kelly daniel thank you
most of all let's thank you america
because you're why we do the show this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show
did you know over 18 million people
listen to the ramsay show every week
and a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country
to find a station near you head to
thermzyshow.com
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this
is the ramsey show it's where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life
your money your work career
your relationships mental emotional
health we're going to cover it all
because it all
matters in relation to you being who you
are
created to be i'm ken coleman host of
the ken coleman show which is
on the ramsey network and my colleague
is dr john dolone he's holds up the dr
john deloney show
on the ramsay network as well and we are
here for you this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight eight two five five
two two five so question i get a lot on
the ken coleman show uh can i
switch jobs during the baby steps the
answer is yes many times
it's the promotion you need and the
financial boost
so i'm gonna help you with some big
shovel stuff uh
john's gonna hey you know a lot of times
people can't get through the baby steps
because of relational
and emotional issues all kinds of stuff
mental health
uh john and i'll team up if you're in a
toxic work environment what to do
and john and i team up on that so i want
you to know that you can ask those
questions
and of course your money questions we
are here for you triple eight eight two
five
five two two five let's start it off
this hour in sarasota florida
where jamie joins us jamie you're on the
ramsay show
good afternoon gentlemen how are you
guys today we're having a blast what's
going on with you
wonderful well thank you so much for uh
everything that you do to help
uh everyone that listens to y'all
um so here's my situation and uh
i'm 39 uh married
i'm uh i have a child and i have a
two-year-old and another one that is due
in july
so i'm already uh we are already i
should say on
baby step seven wow i and by
nature oh you know we uh obviously we or
maybe said seven we have
already you know money and savings and
everything
uh by nature i um i am naturally
stingy i am and i want to become more
generous
so i am wondering what would be some
practical ways to become more generous
so that i can
because in baby step 7 is talking about
giving so how can i be
generous and smart at the same time with
the finances that i have man i love that
question jamie i love your heart dude so
why why are you stingy i was
i grew up kind of um always uh
how do i say this kind of thinking that
i didn't have enough you know and i
never
lacked anything but i also never um
i always thought you know i'm always
thinking for the future for the future
kind of like how you guys teach you know
and i'm already thinking about
you know my kids braces and their
college tuition and all that kind of
stuff
um my wife on the other hand she's
extremely generous sometimes i think
she's a little too generous where
people take advantage of but i want to
be
generous and you know smart at the same
time because
sometimes people take advantage of
generous people uh
but you know i guess this is the reason
why i'm asking this question
so it sounds like beneath the
because you're clearly smart you're 39
you're a millionaire right you know how
math works
and you're very disciplined and you're
intentional yet but maybe almost there
okay so it sounds like
beneath the fear
that i think any rational person has is
i'm not gonna have enough
that's a that's a base fear that people
have
you mentioned several times this this
idea of
uh being taken advantage of that
somebody's going to pull it over on you
and where does that come from
you've been taken advantage of before
yes
actually um and it's because uh you know
it's funny because it actually happened
um uh you know not so much with friends
but
mainly with family um you know where
we extend the hand and um you know we
kind of felt
maybe in the past that we have um gotten
pooped on
and pardoned my expression but you know
uh
though those things have really kind of
marked us
and you know we know that obviously we
know we need to we realize the
importance of setting boundaries
but um you know but it's the whole idea
of
you know of giving you know for me it's
something that i want to get to a point
where
it's just so you know so free in that
sense you know and without
obviously being a little too free to get
what i'm saying so here's here's two
two two things to think through
a guy named mitch changed my life when
it came to giving back in college
that's back when we had nothing and um
he had a little bit better job and he
was a little bit better with his money
and one morning some kid came and
knocked on the door
and said you know fill in the blank
we're
selling something or we need some money
for down the street whatever
and mitch said hang on i don't have any
cash but hold on
and i wrote him a check a sizable check
and everyone in the house you know a
bunch of college knuckleheads and i was
like oh
he's gonna take that money and go do
this or that and i'll never forget what
mitch said
he said well that's on him my gift
was he gave me a need and
my gift was fulfilled an obligation i
had in my heart to help
and if somebody wants to take advantage
of me that's going to be between them
and the mirror
not me and then there's a second thing
which is
and i've learned this by sitting by dave
there is an intentionality
there is a point when you start enabling
people and so
like you talked about with family and
boundaries right so when you know you're
actually participating in somebody
hurting themselves or hurting other
people
whether it's through supporting
addiction or whether it's fill in the
blank
then you have an obligation to stop so
if i'm in your seat
i'm going to do two things number one
i'm going to sit down with my wife and
be
have a dreaming session who are people
we would love to serve
help what gets us going ken talks about
passion when it comes to work
what are we passionate about serving
other people something in your life
it may be people who get taken advantage
of maybe that's where your passion is
what is that thing you can contribute to
in your community the second thing is i
would set some relatively aggressive
goals
and then the third thing is this and i'm
making these up off top of my head
brother
is i want to feel and see that
transaction
you know where i get the greatest joy is
when i
am at a restaurant and i see somebody
working like bananas yeah
she is working so hard he's working so
hard
and i'm gonna obnoxiously tip that
person i'm going to blow my budget for
the whole month
but i'm going to tip like crazy and you
just watch them look at that check
my heart feels good but i know that
their their their
electric bill is taking care of that
month because of that one meal that's
when
you start seeing the impact in your soul
and in their soul when it comes to
giving
jamie i just got to add i think john
gave you some great things here but but
remind remind yourself that you've been
burned with family and you are talking
about setting boundaries and set the
boundaries and know that you're not
going to make that
you're going to make that mistake again
so be free from that you're free you
know what that's like going to do it
again second thing i would mention is
i think john is right and i was going to
say i would
encourage you today or tomorrow your
favorite drive-through place
just pay just start small and build this
muscle because you're scared
and you don't trust people if you want
to get over stingy start small here's
what i want you to do
next drive through say hey person behind
me
how much is their deal i'm going to take
care of the next time you go to a
restaurant your bill's 50 bucks
tip 100 on top yeah do something small
that you can see and begin to feel
that positive chemical that gets
released
when you go oh that was really fun and
then just kind of
build up
just start giving don't think just give
don't move more ramsay show coming right
[Music]
up
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers to recommend
blinds.com is no exception they offer
high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters
with easy online ordering free shipping
and a guaranteed perfect fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's
special savings
[Music]
uh
[Music]
the ramsay show continues from our
ramsey solutions
studios in nashville thrilled to have
you with us i'm ken coleman joined by my
colleague
dr john dilloni and we're taking you
through this hour triple eight
eight two five five two two five triple
eight eight two five
five two two five uh john you know this
i'm talking to people every day that are
stuck and disengaged in their current
job and
uh ramsey solutions is a solution for
that if you're searching for a new job
uh our get hired live stream event
brought to you by yours truly
tuesday april the 27th is for you it's a
one night event
tuesday april 27th 8 eastern 7 central
you'll learn how to get clear on what
you do best
get qualified for the job you want and
get connected to job opportunities
and this is for people that are starting
out if you're a college kid
if you're trying to upgrade get a bigger
shovel
or you're trying to switch careers the
bottom line is you're trying to
win because that's what getting hired is
you're beating the competition
then this event is for you join me
tuesday april the 27th we're gonna have
a live crowd
about 200 people and we haven't sold out
of that yet so if you're in driving
distance of nashville
or live in the national area and you
want to join us we're gonna do some
special stuff for all you folks
uh go text the word hired
hired to 33789 text the word higher to
33789 ticket start at just
20 it's tuesday april the 27th eight
eastern
seven central get hired hear from our
ramsey solutions world headquarters
let's go to scott who joins us in las
vegas nevada scott
how can we help hi guys so
i have a situation where i have
a 16 year old truck i paid it off in
2010
and my dad always told me hey start
saving
so when you get you have to buy and
purchase a new truck or a new car
uh you need to pay it out outright so
i'm at a point right now where my truck
is kind of it's older it's
it's i feel like every year can maybe
something can happen
but i also owe 100 about 157 000 on my
mortgage
and i'm wondering if i just what's the
best route is it to
maybe possibly put that money towards my
mortgage
and i'm talking about i have about
almost a hundred thousand dollars in my
savings and i have about
35 i'd say about 35 for emergency
uh and the rest i would you know i was
going to put down a truck
or put down a car eventually but i
wanted to know like what's the best
route to go dude go buy a truck and then
pay the rest down on your house man
you're overthinking this that's it
you got 100 000 in the bank you know
what that makes you a unicorn
yeah above and beyond your emergency
fund i'm assuming you have no debt
correct
the only bit i have is my house yeah
that's right yeah i understand that but
other than that
so yeah john's right what are you
worried about
well i don't well so i mean my truck is
fine but i feel like it could die at any
minute
right like yeah well oh scott scott
scott if your truck
dies at any moment you got a hundred
grand sitting in the bank
there's absolutely zero to worry about
okay do you i mean like you wanted
one time my wife bought a corolla and we
agreed
that when the corolla finally died i
could get a new car
did you still early no you know why
because you can't kill a corolla
oh it will be true it will be what they
drive after the apocalypse
corolla right somewhere a toyota
executive is writing that down you can't
i'm just telling you
so i got to a point where i'd get in it
every morning and go please don't start
please don't start doing it
is that where you're at scott i mean it
is and
so here's but here's the grand here's my
thing though is like
i know i want to get eventually i want
to get a tesla cyber truck whenever
those come out
okay that's not going to be like two or
three years so i'm hoping my truck
lasts that long right so i'm hoping on
that but that's what i mean is like do
should i just start and that's my
question should i just start focusing on
putting money towards my
my home payment and then eventually you
know but i wouldn't buy a hundred
thousand dollar truck until my house was
paid off
yeah it's not that it's like 60
something thousand same same difference
yeah it's a lot of money yeah so here's
yeah scott
buddy go get something or keep driving
this thing and then put it
let let's do this here's what i'd like
to see you do because i i think he needs
real direction yeah let's get a hundred
thousand dollars burning a hole in your
pocket seriously i think
and you're frustrated that you drive
kind of yeah
a beater truck yeah and you got a
hundred thousand dollars yeah so
so if you're frustrated you've got the
money to go buy it but go buy something
that retains its value pretty decently
and then
uh and then if you if you can afford the
tesla thing down the road
uh then you're going to get most of your
money back or you're going to get a good
chunk back you know so if you buy a
one of those toys what are those toyota
trucks that just hold their value for
fundraising
tundras tacomas you know look dude
here's the deal i'd pay the house off i
i would pay a big
chunk down on the house you got the
emergency fund in place
because now you're really stacking money
um
so just walk the baby steps out and stop
thinking about this but yeah if you want
to go buy a nice car go buy a nice car
my goodness gracious
what's the psychology there john i think
he's got a hundred thousand dollars
burner holmes pocket
i think he doesn't want to spend it
though yeah but you're getting that mick
like
i've had that where it's the kind of an
uppity feeling i drive an old truck and
i think
i got a nice j what am i doing and then
i got to go back to say this truck's
great
it's getting me where i need to be i've
got other goals right my goal as a
reverse of his
i want to pay my house off first right
so i'm gonna try to and by the way
nothing wrong with the truck he said
nothing's wrong with the truck
so keep driving the truck just wants it
to what do i do if it dies
get another one you got a hundred grand
scott
he needs to take a couple deep breaths
you got a breathing regimen for him yeah
it's just he's
tight man it's just that's right
again one of those not too complex
things yeah fantastic they can go get
the wemhop app
and uh learn how to breathe triple eight
eight two
five five two two five you're listening
to the ramsey show let's go
north of the border toronto ontario
where vinnie joins us vinnie you're on
the ramsay show
hi how are you guys doing oh we're
having a blast what's up vinny
so yeah my situation is um
i'm basically a recent college graduate
i got twenty thousand dollars
in debt uh the thing is that i'm since
the pandemic
it's been a struggle trying to get a job
and everything
so you know i've been always trying to
you know
go get into real estate investing it's
been like my dream goal
not my dream goal but like one of the
things i really want to do and you know
the situation that i'm in right now it's
pretty like
you know i would say like it's losing my
confidence on a daily basis so i'm just
wondering like what like
i'm just trying to get some sort of
advice out here you know in order for me
to deal with the situation
well first of all don't attach your
confidence
to and your ability to eventually be a
real estate investor to your current
situation so
your situation vinnie is not your
sentence
this isn't a life sentence you're not a
loser all of a sudden because you're
recently out of college
and you got student loan debt you're
having a hard time get a job you need to
separate those two
number one and then let's get serious
about getting hired if it's two or three
part-time jobs just to get yourself some
momentum right now
the quickest way to get out of a rut is
to get busy is to do something
but sitting around and commiserating
not that not that that's what you're
doing but just sitting around and
soaking in your frustration is not the
way to move forward
get to work start making some money
follow the baby steps knock the 20 000
out a young guy like you should be able
to do that
sacrifice big time john what would you
add to that
vinny do you want to get into real
estate so you can try to short circuit
the deal you're going to borrow some
money
grab a house flip it try to earn that
cash and then roll and roll is that what
you're talking about
yeah that like yeah flipping it and all
that stuff yeah
yeah but you got to do that with cash
here's what's gonna happen you're gonna
go
buy three properties you're gonna
leverage yourself to the hilt the
market's lost its freaking mind
and then you're gonna it's gonna roll
over on you and you're gonna be bust
yeah the market right now here in
toronto is messed up like it's uh dude
that's always just one no listen brother
you're way
you're years away from real estate
investing i don't want to be the
the guy that has feelings but you're way
far away right now you need to learn if
you want to go sell houses and get a
real estate license and go work in a
real estate
office and learn how the thing works
listen to what he just said vinnie
that's the deal you learn the business
but brother yes
don't go take a bunch of loans out and
try to roll some houses over because
it's going to roll right on top of you
and you're going to be bust
go pay your loans off and scratch and
claw and scratch the clock ken gave you
the best psychological advice
when you get in a rut go do something
yeah
don't just sit there vinny get to work
three part-time jobs
six part-time jobs pay the debt off get
qualified if you want to be in real
estate use the proximity principle hang
on the line
kelly let's give him a copy of my book
start getting around people that are
doing what you want to do
but you better do it the cash way that
means you got to get to work and work
for a while and sell a bunch of houses
save all that money buy a ca a house
cash and begin that process you can get
there
but you're gonna have to work your way
there vinnie come on man
get out of the house get to work don't
move this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsey show i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague dr john delonia
we're taking you through
this hour of the ramsey show find out
for yourself why blinds.com is the
number one
online retailer of custom window
covering you get free samples free
shipping with the new promos they run
every month you'll save
even more use the promo code ramsey to
get
the best deal today's question there you
go
from barbara in virginia john all right
barbara asks my husband and i
are debt-free except for a zero percent
car loan of thirteen thousand dollars
should we pay it off or continue with
the 548 dollar a month payment
we are retired and have monthly income
of six thousand dollars
our retirement portfolio is one million
dollars
yes paid off yesterday and then be done
the only thing i wish you would have
done in reading that was do the dr evil
1 million dollars yeah simple
because here's the thing it's not a
you're not playing a math game you're a
millionaire yeah
you're paying you're playing a how many
change
are hitched behind me how many people am
i
subject to and right now you are
willingly
subject to a bank for no financial
reason not because you have to not
because you're stuck not because you
don't have enough money you're just
choosing
every week to be indebted to a bank
and at that point it your dollar amount
doesn't make any sense
yeah good stuff there triple eight eight
two five five two two five let's go to
orlando florida where chuck is on the
line chuck
how can we help hey how are you guys
what's going on hey uh my
two ac systems in the house uh are about
12 years old and they tell me from about
10 to 15 that they're gonna die
uh-oh and uh it's gonna run about
dollars 11 replace them and uh
i have um i have a good savings account
and i have some stock
so my question is should i pay it all
off
or you know finance consider financing
it
i just don't know don't finance the air
conditioning
just just do not do that how much do you
have in savings
uh about 12 000. okay do you have any
other debt
uh no i'm debt-free except for the
mortgage
okay is that 12 000 include your
emergency fund or is that above that
uh it does it does okay well that's why
we have stock
how much in stock 46 000
just in single stocks or company stock
uh
single stocks uh i i invest myself
okay yeah i would actually sell the
single stock and roll that into an
emergency fund of some sort
and then you've got your twelve thousand
dollars to
um pay your air conditioners off and
then you owe nobody any money you're not
gonna take a loan out on a depreciating
asset which would be
the air conditioners the day you put
them in are gonna start losing value
what's your income chuck what do you
bring home uh about 60
a year okay and uh
how much based on your budget right now
how much are you putting away a month or
how much could you if you move the
budget around a little bit how much
could you put away each month towards
the ac replacement fund
um well
i die geez
probably that's a good question probably
four or five hundred dollars
all right i think you got a couple
options there right we
you know range of solutions we don't you
know we're not saying that you know
being in
stocks is evil or wrong we just don't
recommend it because it's a real roller
coaster you can get hurt
uh so i think john gave you a great
option but i just wanted you to
to have in your mind wait a second if i
could put 400 a month away
right now the units are working correct
um yes they are yeah so well yes and no
uh actually the uh inside unit is uh
got a slow leak on it oh they went ahead
and charged it a couple of days ago
and um so it's on its way out yeah but
let me but let me say this i've been
down this road before i've owned four
houses now
and i've had this happen and here's what
i know about text they'll come out there
and they'll tell you all the things
wrong with it's like the mechanic
doesn't mean they're evil but that's
just the way they roll
and they go this thing's gonna die
somewhere between
uh year 12 and year or whatever and all
of a sudden what does that do
our emotions go oh my gosh the clock is
ticking well first of all
the tech doesn't know exactly when it's
going to die or he wouldn't be doing
hvac repair all right he'd be in the
prediction business second thing is
even though that hose is leaking you
know there's i like to always ask okay i
get it
i get that i'm going to have to replace
this can i fix that
but how much is it going to cost to fix
the hose and keep that going because
if we could keep that going and extend
the life of this thing with some
uh every once in a while repairs that's
not going to be a big financial hit to
you you've got the emergency fund for
that very reason
and if you begin to save 400 bucks a
month
to replacing one of those units well you
can do the math
you know you know how quickly you can
get there and and begin at least take
care of one i seriously doubt that both
are going to quit the same day
so i just don't want you to act out of
fear is my point
let's act out of facts what are the
facts right now
and let's go that direction and chuck
here here's a an interesting way to
think of it
following ken's line of thinking you can
either start saving money on your own
now
or you can finance this thing and pay
that same money on the back end to
somebody else
i'd much rather own my own destiny in
that in that scenario
yeah right and again john's advice was
really good
you've got stock yeah if i'm you if i if
yeah if i'm in your situation i sell the
stock tomorrow
i it's everything's rocking and rolling
i sell the stock i've got emergency fund
there is no
no drama in my house and then i'd i'd
probably just go ahead and replace them
yeah call it good yeah if that's if
that's if you're really worried about it
but
you know you're not getting hopefully
not getting killed in the stock market
and you're up right now go ahead and use
that that is your money
and uh that's a really risky thing we'd
really love for you to consider
our investment strategy and reach out to
a smart investor pro
go to ramseysolutions.com find a smart
investor pro or two or three in your
area and interview them and start that
investment strategy that way
but you've got options here you've got
several options but one thing i don't
like is
when when we feel like you know
something's wrong with the car
i mean i can tell you how many times
i've had mechanics go well this is this
is probably gonna happen
and i go has it happened no it hasn't
happened it's probably gonna happen okay
great
and about what is that going to cost
when it happens
okay just and you just got that money
and
i'm just wait what happened yeah i'm not
going to just drive that car every day
going gee i hope this doesn't happen
today
if it happens we got the aaa we'll get
her over there
we'll fix it i you know just this oh
i've gotta move money now i gotta come
up with money now it's like
do you sometimes the answer is
unequivocally
yes yeah but sometimes it's like no
actually
well before i go buy two air
conditioning systems let me have
somebody else come out and look at them
and get a second opinion before i go
spend 12 grand you know yeah that's a
you know what that's a great point this
is the kind of thing i would really do
i'm glad you brought this up i'm telling
my wife she's on facebook right i'm not
on
facebook i'm going to facebook the whole
neighborhood we live in a neighborhood
the neighborhood's got a page there's
all these next door apps i don't know
all the stuff that i'm i'm not on i mean
you could go hey
anybody got some hvac experience i'm
getting some
i'm getting some different stories here
i got a story that seems pretty gruesome
anybody you know you just never know
some guy goes yeah i do it i'm your
neighbor i'll come over and take a look
at it
why wouldn't you exhaust all options
before you decide to chunk 12 grand
into two new units now the thing going
for this guy is and i get it he's in
orlando it's it's about to get hotter
than the surface of the sun
you need some air conditioning that's
right yeah i i
yeah you know what i'm saying yeah it's
it's that fear thing you talked about
yeah you know i get the temptation to
man i'll just let's just do it right now
i'll figure out how to pay for it later
and no we're not there let's just be
intentional
yeah yeah i mean goodness gracious i
i grew up in houston so i know what
happens when the air conditioner goes
out is it hotter in houston texas in
july or orlando florida i don't know i
think it's about the same yeah it's just
once it crosses the 110 mark it just
hurts yeah
kelly's shaking her head i think the
humidity in texas and florida is
probably equal
and that's really what's going on you
know the humidity is unbelievable
but you know john we talked about this
early i want people to get this we have
a little bit of fun here with chuck
but you know john's right you know i've
learned this from you
and i talk about this too when you've
got a fear write it out get it out of
your head and let's see if it's
really really truly something i should
be afraid of if i stand close to the
fire
get burned that's a real fear if i try
this career i'm going to be homeless
and live under a bridge that's not or if
it costs 125 bucks to recharge american
engineers for the next three months
yeah i got 90 days to yeah get some
other opinions and ideas and solutions
don't they make some kind of tape for
that kind of stuff it's got to be some
tape at lowe's or home depot
i don't
[Applause]
[Music]
well i don't know how to fix anything so
i i willingly step into the laughter
there folks
hey i'll tell you what i do know we're
coming back
to continue to help you this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
you're listening to the ramsey show
thrilled to have you with us triple
eight eight two five five two two five
i'm ken coleman joined by dr john delony
and we are talking about your life
your relationships your money your work
your career path
mental health we're talking about it all
triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's go to ann arbor
michigan home of my beloved
michigan wolverines andrew joins us
there andrew how can we help
hey john hey ken how you guys doing
today we're having a blast what's up
ah my wife and i are 25 years old and uh
we're looking to have kids in the next
three to five years um
we don't want to look back and regret
not ever moving out of state
um so i was just kind of looking for
some advice what what do you
what's the regret you fear uh just
staying in the city so we live in a
small town
just outside ann arbor our kind of fear
is that you never go to the mountains
you're never
never really get to live or experience
living out of state
we have a lot of family members that are
kind of doing that and it's
something that we're just kind of
considering so why don't you just go
move
well it's always come back to finances
and uh the
projection of our future right well why
not travel have you traveled to some of
these places that you
wonder about living in yes sir
yes um so we we would love to go down to
tennessee um
there's there's opportunities with my
company um there's also opportunities to
go down to the carolinas
um really a lot of regions that we'd
like to live but we
when we have kids we want to be back
here in michigan so the
kind of question i have for you um goes
back to our debt
we currently have about 15 000 in
savings that's including our
our emergency fund we have about 98
thousand dollars
in mortgage debt um we have seventy
thousand dollars
saved in our retirement and combined we
make a
pre-tax and pre-contribution income of a
hundred and thirty-five thousand dollars
um so i guess the the question i have is
and
we're projected to i'm protected to pay
off the house between
august and october of next year um
so i guess my my question goes back to
whether we should
should just wait a year um
how much is your house worth andrew how
much is your house worth
and i know you've got 98 000 left so
what would it sell for right now give me
a modest
projection uh i would think around
between 230 and 250 thousand dollars bro
i don't know what you're worried about
i'm gonna let john speak this move to
the psychology but as long as you don't
have an interruption in income
um you guys you're debt free except your
home you could pay the home off right
now
right now if you sell it right now you
guys have got big time
cash and if you replace your income you
said there are opportunities in the
carolinas and opportunities in tennessee
take the opportunities and you know what
if you wanna if you wanna have kids in
three to five years
by the way you have no control over that
zero okay but let's just say that plays
out for you
um listen to andrew you guys could rent
for two or three years
it's not a sin to rent you're debt-free
if
you're gonna come back eventually or you
you might have enough money it sounds
like you might gonna have enough money
to put a nice down payment on something
else and sell that
when the kids come along john you want
to speak to the fear here
it's bigger than that you may have find
some wonderful community in tennessee or
the carolinas in three to five years
never come back and never go back and so
what you're
what you're doing is you're projecting
the other side of a coin while you're
you're projecting what living in on the
tail side is going to be where you live
on the head side
and so you're never gonna know until you
go and
here's what you're looking for you're
looking for an iron clad should we or
shouldn't we
that doesn't exist you're just gonna
have to jump or you're gonna have to be
really happy that you didn't jump
or like my family we always said him
we'd love to live outside
of texas it was until we were in our
late late 30s before we finally
made the jump and our kids were young
and we never thought we'd do that and we
did
and so you put some artificial
constraints on yourself
and then you're bound in by these
artificial constraints and feel like you
can't move and then
feeling like you can't move makes you
frustrated and your wife frustrated
you're only 25. we should be doing
another
man now's the time those boundaries
aren't real
right you said it was a financial
problem andrew or a financial issue
there's no financial issues sell that
house
yeah so let's move move this summer uh
let me just touch up stacey and i had a
great plan
we really did we thought we'd be married
two years and have a baby guess what
seven and a half years infertility yep
four years for us
i mean listen you got no control over
that
so you're you're you just need to do
this
i love the fact of a young couple john
that's in the financial shape they're in
selling their house and going on this
grand adventure because financially this
is not a silly decision
it's not even risky and you get
somewhere and you're 28 and the whole
thing implodes
yeah you got plenty of time to have a
new adventure somewhere else yeah you're
fine you can always go back to
your original small town let's go to
jenny next in colorado springs jenny how
can we help
hey guys thank you guys so much for
taking my call i'm a little nervous
that's okay um
okay okay so um
i um i have a business um
it's a waxing business in the springs
i've got two employees
just this week i signed
another year lease thinking it was just
a normal situation
to go ahead and sign another year lease
for the two suites that i do rent from
from my landlord
last night i found out
the landlord is planning on on selling
the buildings
um and i just signed the lease this week
and found out yesterday my question is
because a real estate is so crazy here
and really hot in the springs
um would it be advantageous
to look into purchasing my own building
a little bit about my husband and i um
my business cleared about a hundred
thousand dollars last year after tax
um and we um
we owe 182 000 on our house
we were hoping to go ahead and have our
house fully paid for
in a year and a half uh and we make
about 2.95
total between my husband and i um
can you afford to buy a building with
cash
well we don't have the for a commercial
property
from my understanding you're supposed to
have 25 to 30 percent
down to purchase the the building now my
landlord would love to sell it to me
but she wants to sell it for 750
thousand dollars
so i would have to probably have two
hundred and twenty five thousand dollars
jenny jenny jenny you didn't answer his
question but we know the answer
the answer is no you don't have the cash
to buy a building
so if you don't have the cash to buy a
building this is not a good decision for
you
and i don't think you have anything to
worry about just because
your current landlord is selling the
building
whoever the new owner is going to be
they want people
renting leasing from them i just don't
see with the business you've got going
this is an unnecessary question it's
just you don't even need to think about
buying
anything at all just keep going what
okay really like what if there was a
property that was
less than that that i could occupy the
majority of the space and then have
and not even have a landlord what if a
meteorite
comes directly at us at any moment
or whatever my car gets a jet engine put
here's the thing you can what if and you
it's they're all going to be right and
fun and adventurous what ifs
and the chances of them coming through
what i don't want you to do is to go to
colorado springs
take out a giant mortgage on a building
have that entire
market slow down and you're stuck with a
building you can't
fully fund or you can't fully lease or
you're going to have to
undersell the market you're going to
find yourself in a mess and then you go
from being a business owner to a
business that's doing really good
to being a landowner right to being a
someone who's in the real estate
business which is a whole
other business so it all sounds good if
you can walk in and pay cash for a
building
awesome great do it tomorrow if you
can't
don't bind yourself up into a whole
other adventure and i know you can sit
down and flip over a napkin and make the
math work for you
um i wouldn't do that jenny you and your
husband make really good money your
business is growing you got a new
landlord and it somehow freaked you out
and then you've created a worse scenario
than actually just continuing to
step forward you're holding a year lease
in your hand
big deal you're good you're fine you got
this
stay the course hey i want to thank our
producer ben hill
our associate producer kelly daniel and
my colleague dr john deloney
but most of all we want to thank you
america this is your show this
is the ramsey show
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
thermzyshow.com
thanks for listening
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions
broadcasting from the dollar car rental
studio this
is the ramsey show it's where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
your life
i'm ken coleman joined by my colleague
dr john deloney and we
are a part of the ramsey network and we
are
your hosts this hour triple eight eight
two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five
five two two five we'll talk about your
money
we'll talk about your emotional and
mental health we'll talk about your job
are you just working a job
you wanna make more money you wanna get
that shovel bigger so you can get out of
debt
faster you want to actually work on
purpose and enjoy mondays
well that's what we talk about on the
ken coleman show and dr john delaney
helping you
on all things emotional mental health
relationships
and we'll talk about your money as well
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's start it off with amanda
in colorado springs colorado amanda how
can we help
hey guys oh my goodness thank you so
much for taking my call it's such an
honor to speak with you guys
well the honor is all ours what's going
on today
okay so i want to make this as concise
as possible
um i am 33 years old
and i have a really rare
terminal illness um that is in
the essentially what i've been told is
kind of the end stages
um and really at this point i'm kind of
out living the timeline that
doctors have actually given me um which
is amazing
and you know um i'm still believing that
the lord could heal me and um but
realistically i feel like my body
is failing and um
i have grown up with the dave ramsey
principles
i'm out of debt i got to live my dream
job
in ministry and do all the things um but
i am kind of right now unsure
um and feel like i'm in kind of
uncharted territory as far as
what to do with finances um
in the like few in the like
present day life
um and how to set myself up well not
knowing
um kind of as i call it like terminal
without a timeline
so i like i said i'm out of debt and i
have um
because of some disability back pay and
some different things i have
some money and so because of my
illness i wasn't able to like withstand
the cold of colorado winter so
i came down to florida and lived
for what i thought was kind of going to
be the ending like
last six months of my life and i'm still
here um
but i i don't know kind of how to
navigate and um yeah so
i just wanted to kind of get some
perspective on that
well amanda you you're just you're
telling of your story
is giving us all uh perspective on our
own lives
i don't know that there's a person in
the united states that's listening to
this that didn't just
stop for a second turn the radio up and
so thank you so much for being brave
and for telling us about that and um
from the bottom of the heart i'm
heartbroken for you
and your attitude and bravery and way
you are making meaning of this
is an inspiration to me personally to
all of us
is how do you stare what we all know is
coming right how we stare in the face
and also be able to
to recognize and find beauty in every
day and we get to live our dream job and
hey i'm gonna go six months and ride out
the last few
months in in florida a place i want to
be and now what do i do so
um thank you so much for sharing your
story with us yeah um
so it sounds like there's two parts to
this number one is the personal
and the second is the financial when you
say
you want to know what to do with your
money explain that a little bit are you
wondering
who to leave it to do you have enough
money to get through
treatment or tell me what your money
concerns are
kind of all the above and so
i like i said um i
was actually kind of in a um
not really feeling like i was debt-free
and that kind of thing
um but then um once i kind of navigated
through
um like disability and different things
and now
um i get a small amount of disability
each month
um i just i guess for me
do oh how about this do you have enough
money to pay your bills
i do yeah i do and i um
are you single do you have anybody that
is a dependent okay
i'm totally single my mom was a single
mom
and so really she's the only person that
i'm connected to
and um yeah so i guess the thing is
i have enough money that i could live
for a pretty long
amount of time i think probably longer
than i can
um but i guess it's just that fear of
spending it like frivolously
um you know just living you know without
like i've always been a hard worker
and i've always like been
self-sufficient and so just to like
not have a plan and i don't know i guess
that's what i'm asking
is is i feel like the dave ramsey way is
to always have a plan
yeah i don't know so yeah
your plan in your heart and mind you
know how to make a financial plan
um honey you've got enough money to
get you to the end of the ride and so
your goal now
is not like debt free your goal is not
everyday millionaire that's not your
goal
your goal is to slide in to
the end with no tread left on your tires
in a safe and responsible way obviously
but your your last months your last year
can be about service
can be about visiting people that you
want to visit can be about
um walking dog it can be about anything
you want it to be
because quite frankly you're a you're
literally an angel that i'm speaking to
right now yeah
and so it's surreal to have outlived the
outlived
right they gave you a short deadline and
that's
you grieved it and then you went to
you you set off into your ship for your
last ride and then
the ride went all the way around and
then you landed back to shore now you're
kind of yeah you don't know what to do
right
and so well i started a blog called
terminal ain't terrible
because i'm like just gotta live the
rest of my life there you go
so i wanna hear what you wanna do is
there people you wanna go visit
is it serving the least of these you
sound like a person who is so committed
to other people
what are the things that you want to do
you get a rare moment you get a rare
moment that many folks won't have which
is
i've got a clear heart and a clear mind
and i am financially okay
and but i i know the end is near i know
it's coming
what do you want to do yeah well i've
done a lot of writing
um i um you know i i listened to
ken's radio show and kind of was like
trying to
figure out like a job with like writing
and creating a blog and monetizing it
but
i think like perspective-wise that was a
little bit like
time-wise not gonna work um amanda
here's what i would tell you
number one we're we're going to be
praying for you as john said you
inspired us listen
you need to decide you want to leave
some money for mom if you don't have a
will get a will
kelly will connect you if you need that
but i would decide
how you're going to live and it's about
relationships from here on
from here on out that's jobs it's all
relationships and i love that you're
writing but it really is about what you
want to do
this is you leaving your mark we're
honored that you called us that you
shared this story
amanda make it count this is the ramsay
[Music]
show
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that even in adversity
that you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance
career training and a paycheck to help
you avoid debt
no matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
the ramsay show continues from our
ramsey solutions worldwide headquarters
in nashville
so excited that you've joined us i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague
dr john dolone and we're taking your
calls this hour on your life your money
your relationships your mental emotional
health your work
that advancing making more money
whatever we're taking
that call for you triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five five two two
five when it comes to life i don't
know if there's a bigger life change
than buying a home or maybe getting
married having a baby
and when that change comes comes at you
there's a lot coming you're thinking
about a lot
and you need to make sure that you're
thinking about the right insurance
coverage
those big changes are overwhelming but
it would be even more overwhelming if
you find yourself in a situation where
you and your family
are in a hole because you weren't
covered if not having the time or energy
is what's keeping you from getting the
right insurance coverage use one of our
endorsed local provider or elp
insurance agents to help elps are
independent agents that shop a variety
of insurance options to find you the
best
option and then they explain all the
technical lingo so you know exactly what
you're getting
for free all you have to do is text the
word
insurance to 33789 text the word
insurance
to 33789 to get connected with an elp
and get the coverage that you need text
the word insurance
to 33789
let's go to the city of angels los
angeles california nancy joins us on the
line there nancy how can we help
hi it's an honor you guys to speak to
you both well he honors our all ours
how can we help well i'm calling because
i'm in a bit of a conundrum i'm 46 years
old i'm a single mom
and i am about to start baby step 3b
but i am concerned because um
i don't have very much saved for
retirement
i do have a pension but
my dream is to someday own a home
and while i'm you know cash flowing my
daughter's college as well
i'm just kind of wondering what should i
do should i begin
to save for retirement and just kind of
um not be as intense in terms of saving
for the down payment i know it's going
to slow me down
or should i just focus my efforts in
saving for the down payment
and make sure that when i am ready to
purchase that home that i can pay it off
before i retire why are you cash flowing
your daughter's college
i'm sorry um why are you cash flowing
your daughter's college
um because i don't want her to you know
be in the same situation that i was in
i mean i had a lot of student loans
and um i just wanted to make sure that
she's you know
shut up and that when she graduates that
she doesn't have
so i'll let ken talk through the money
part but i've seen this with parents
over the years working in colleges
and they end up making a trade
unintentionally and the trade is
i don't want my students to have student
loan debt because i remember the pain of
that
and so instead of investing in their
retirement
they put that money into the college
fund and what that
what that means is instead of the kid
having student loans to pay off
or having to figure out another college
option that may be cheaper less
prestigious et cetera
they assure that mom's gonna have to
move in and that kid's gonna have to pay
for mom and old age
so there's a hundred percent chance that
you're gonna have to retire there's a
hundred percent chance you're gonna get
old
and there is a million options
other than having to cash flow your kids
college
and it ends up just being a reverse
burden it's going to be a different one
but it's still going to exist there if
that makes sense
and so i'll pass it on again i i just
want to put that out there because i see
i hear and see parents do that all the
time
your priority right now has got to be
making sure you've got a home
making sure you've got retirement and
then
working to figure out a solution for
your daughter in college yeah nancy
you're a great mom first of all
i mean yes you're just got a huge heart
and i understand
why you're doing what you're doing but
john's absolutely right this is not your
burden
and if you walk the baby steps out okay
and you know the baby
steps so you're in the 3b which is kind
of developed over time right
the baby step 4 is 15 toward retirement
and
then we move towards the college and all
that stuff and so you're just in a
situation where you're behind the eight
ball there and i think you feel that
burden and you shouldn't feel the burden
i think i think you and your daughter
got to figure something out
what i want to know is is what's your
income
about 105 a year 105. do you have room
for advancement there or do you feel
like you're i mean
tell me what your prospects are as you
see them
um i do love my job um i'm very happy
doing what i'm doing
um there is over time you know the
opportunity for my income to
to increase um how much are you putting
towards your daughter what's your
monthly spend on the daughter's
education
not very much she she understood
from the very beginning that she had to
stay here in california
and she's doing state college in roughly
a year
um i pay about two thousand dollars
two thousand dollars four thousand
dollars a year
for for her tuition and books because
her father does help
okay so you're putting forth very okay
that's good
that's really good i'm glad to hear that
that that is good
um but again i think what john said is
right i mean what we want to see you do
is
is really begin to get on your on your
uh
your retirement because she can earn
four thousand dollars she can earn four
thousand dollars i'd like to see that
four thousand dollars going towards
you know again if you want to save for
the house that's fine but you need to be
on
if you really want to buy how long
you've been renting by the way i'm
curious
since uh since forever um i didn't
really discover dave ramsey
until about three years ago yeah hold on
a second i don't want you to feel
guilt over that i hear tremendous guilt
and shame over that that's not
that's not a bad thing nancy i want to
set you free from that the reason i
asked is
it's not a sin to rent when financially
you're not
in a position to buy a home and you're
not and i love that you're going after
baby step 3b
but i also want you to to be looking at
your retirement portfolio
and that was my next question so i don't
we got to keep moving here but don't
feel guilt over that yeah
i i rent i've rented for years and years
i just recently bought so it's all good
yeah you're not wasting money nancy now
where are you at retirement to this
moment what do you what do you have say
for retirement
um well like i said i do have a pension
um
and as soon as i mean i didn't really
know very much about investing
i have about i don't know i would say
about 30k
in annuities um and i stopped that
completely once i
decided to you know follow the steps
so i haven't really invested a whole lot
and that's why i think i'm feeling this
sense of of panic and i keep telling
myself well there is a pension but i
know
that well hey don't be done don't be
panicked uh i thought you told me you
were 46 years young did i remember that
correctly
that is correct come on let's hear it
nancy for 1974.
i'm 46 as well so nancy i don't think
i'm i don't think i'm old so i i promise
you i don't think you're old so number
one no more panic
no more guilt and shame over rent can i
get an amen doc
yeah and no more panic here's and listen
listen listen no more guilt and shame
over parenting
yeah more guilt and shame over the
relationship that didn't work out you
got this
no more of it so nancy here real quick
we got to run through some things have
you met with one of our smart vester
pros
and not yet you need to go to
ramseysolutions.com as soon as this call
is over
and as dave has taught us and we say the
same thing i want you to interview three
four five until you get one that feels
like they definitely have the heart of
the teacher and you've got a connection
with them i want you to sit down and let
them see your stuff and say
i just called the ramsay show and here's
where i am now
i've got a little bit of panic and i
know i need a plan and
an absent of a plan the brain goes wild
and then we we get panicky so i want you
to get with a good smart investor pro
and begin to map this thing out
the four thousand dollars we need to
bring that back in
and we need to either put that towards
baby step 3b uh let's look at your
current 401k whatever you've got
going on at work let's let's work
towards that but but i want you to
sit down and figure out what a real
retirement plan looks like and i think
you're going to go okay
i do have time i can be really gazelle
intense now at this level too
and i can catch up it's not too late and
there is an entire culture built around
making moms especially single moms
feel like you are a perpetual screw-up
you've done everything wrong and you'll
continue to that is a lie
you're a great mom you're in a position
now you're not too late to turn it
around
you have turned it around and now it's
getting the right people in your corner
to get down this new path
you're on it nancy you're rocking and
rolling i'm so proud of you yep
take your time take a deep breath the
house will be there
when you're ready for it this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
the ramsay show continues from ramsey
solutions headquarters in nashville
i'm ken coleman joined by my colleague
dr john deloney so grateful that you
have joined us
it is your show america and therefore
we have a phone number for you to jump
in triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five
five two two five let's
go to joe who joins us in harrisburg
pennsylvania joe
you're on the ramsay show hey hey ken
hey dr john how are you guys doing
we are having a blast what's it all
about for you today
okay so i'm 23 um i just graduated
college in may
and i'm a i'm actually a personal
finance teacher it uses dave's high
school curriculum
oh great thank you my question is i have
twelve thousand
five hundred dollars left on my student
loans and i do a monthly budget
um as i should as a personal finance
teacher i go
um yes but i have haven't planned out
that i'll be debt-free
um by the end of summer so end of august
that's how i haven't budged it out
because i'm still living at home with my
parents
um so i'm able to save a lot of money
like that i've already paid off like
about twenty thousand dollars good for
you my question is though since they are
in
deferment until september and there's
all this talk about you know
the possibility of some uh of the debt
being forgiven like i'm not planning on
that
but would it be wrong of me to put my
money
in the savings account that i've
budgeted every month until september
in case it happens then once september
hits and it doesn't happen i just pay
that 12
500 off because my next step would be
buying a house
and i just would be an awful feeling in
my stomach if i could have ten thousand
gone
i could put that towards the house yeah
i you know that's a very logical
question john
and joe i'm gonna tell you something um
there was a point in my life where it
was a possibility that i was going to be
able to dunk a basketball at least that
was
really that was the thought no no no it
never was a possibility
that i'm making my point here and i
don't think it's a possibility that the
government's going to pay your loans off
i just don't see it happening i think
it's i think it's one in a million
chance it happens
uh but to answer your question answer
your question straightforward
it's not wrong you know but that's not
what we're going to recommend
i don't think it's morally wrong it just
puts yourself in a temptation
to if you put that aside and you stop
the plan
a plan that you're going to execute in
just a few months at the end of the
summer
it creates all levels of temptation then
my colleague is far
uh far more qualified to talk about the
psychological there
and so that's why we're never going to
recommend that you do that but it's not
morally wrong
joe here's here's my heart on it you're
a smart guy
is that correct i i
think so that's like the impossible
question i know i set you up here
so you are a smart guy you wouldn't be a
finance he's like uh
no john [ __ ] hey so
at the end of the day where i struggle
with this
is a guy who me and my wife have what
seven degrees between us we had
six figures of student loans and then i
started con
using student loans to consolidate cars
and credit i went bananas with student
loans
all right yeah here's the thing
nobody tricked me every i didn't i
didn't
i didn't count the cost i didn't sit
there and add them up every semester and
see what i
you know how deep the hole was but i
didn't know to do that
right so at the end was that kind of due
to it
but here's the thing i signed my name to
a piece of paper and that paper said hey
if you'll help me get through college
i'll pay you back
and so for me this is an integrity
question
and you are somebody who has a a
blessing and that your parents and you
get along you're allowed to stay there
and save up this money
and there's something in my soul that
wouldn't sleep right knowing that i
waited on the government to bail me out
of the choice that i made
an integrity decision that i signed a
piece of paper saying i'll pay you back
um because you helped me get through
school and so you have the ability
to work really hard and be debt free on
your own two feet
in a few months and there's a part of me
that
as a guy who's walked alongside students
for so many years what i'm going to tell
you is
you're going to have your head held high
brother and
if if you pay it all off in august in
september they say hey we're waving 10
grand
you're going to go you're going to turn
around and what you're going to do
is like most americans should you're
going to get indignant you're going to
say wait a minute
i just worked my butt off to complete
the agreement that i
signed and you're just going to wipe and
then you're gonna say
well so it is i stood up on my own two
feet and not paid it off you can join
the uh ken coleman grumpy
old man club because i paid mine off and
my wife paid hers off
married yeah and it's like i don't think
they should defer that i don't think
they should uh get pay these things off
i don't like it i don't think it's right
all right then if you agree then keep
walking it forward i just didn't want
the fomo you know
hey you know what listen you're gonna
have fomo whether you're just
learn now that fomo's a choice
right it's a choice that's a great call
and you know what else joe you're
rocking it man
yeah pay these things off you can still
live with mom and dad a little longer
and save up for that house payment or
whatever take your time
i gotta tell you this john it's very
normal but now being 46
having gone through the early 20s i got
married at 23.
okay yeah i get it
but you don't have to buy a house no
to prove that you're a success or that
you aren't a loser or whatever the
narrative
is joe doesn't have to be in a hurry to
buy a house not that it's man if you if
you get an apartment at 23 you're just
pouring your money down the drain you're
just flushing it down the toilet
no you're not no you're not you learn
how to grow up you're saving some money
outside of mom and dad's house
right and we're not talking about you
joe talking about anybody who's 23
man and you have the opportunity to live
at home it's a it's a healthy situation
you pay those loans off really fast
and then go live in an apartment for a
few years yeah slow down
save your money let this market cool off
have cash in your hand and go put down
20 30 40 percent on a house when people
need to get out you're gonna get a great
deal on house
yeah just everybody exhale for a second
especially you 22 23 24 year olds
yeah i mean renting is not a sin we got
to say that
over and over and over let's go to
houston texas
where jessica joins us jessica you're on
the ramsay show
hi how are you we're having a blast
jessica what's going on
so my husband and i have completed uh
baby steps one through three good
way to go jessica thank you thank you
we're very proud of it
um and we are currently
we currently just finished baby step
three
but we found it to be very difficult
because we
recently just welcomed our first baby in
december
yes yes yes and we were told that we had
to pay a third amount
for us to have our baby at the hospital
so we paid that it was in the budget we
paid it
but the problem is is that we keep
receiving medical bills
from myself and my son's
stay at the hospital so we found with
step three
it was a constant we were saving for
three to six months and then stopping
and then saving and then stopping
to pay off the medical bills um and now
that we're transitioning
to step four um we're not sure how to
still treat the medical bills if we
should still treat it like it's a
debt because we're fighting that we're
constantly starting and stopping because
we just received these random medical
bills
from when from the birth of our son so i
am in a similar situation not with a
baby
but i went i had to go to the er um over
the christmas holidays
and i went in there and in the er they
had this you know it was
like a robot on an ipad and they brought
them out and they said here's what the
cost is going to be and i have
an hsa so i paid the hsa
and the the amount they wanted i didn't
have that much in my hsa account
and so they said well we'll just move
the what you owe us down i said i don't
want to cash pay i want to give you any
insurance just want to pay cash and get
out of here
so they moved it down and i have this
recorded i said
you're telling me this is the final bill
forever this is it they're like yes your
cash pay you're gonna be able to walk
out of here
we're gonna all high five i said it
again and again and again
and there's this thing saying this call
is being recorded and it's flashing up
there right
and then just the other day i got
another bill so what'd you do
i'm gonna call the hospital and say
you're gonna check your records
i'm not gonna pay anymore we agreed on
this i gave you this cash
and what i think i don't always think
it's the hospital's fault i think
different departments build differently
but there's a central department that
says here's the cause
they need to get their house in order so
what i would do is fight this and give
them a call say here's what we agreed on
i'm not paying this anymore and if you
send me the collections i'm gonna go get
a great attorney
in houston okay don't let him take
advantage of you
you paid your bills you'd be done with
it go
fight this jessica all right don't move
more ramsey show right after the break
[Music]
[Music]
this is the ramsey show i'm ken coleman
joined by my colleague dr john deloney
and we're taking your calls about your
life
your money your relationships
your work triple eight eight two five
five
two two five our scripture of the day
hebrews 10 23 and 24 let us hold
unswervingly to the hope we profess for
he
who promised is faithful and let us
consider how we may spur one another
on toward love and good deeds our quote
of the day from anne frank
no one has ever become poor
by giving that's powerful stuff
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's go to boise idaho where
roberto joins us roberto you're on the
ramsay show
hey guys thank you for having me you bet
what's going on
hey so just a question i'm 24 years old
i'm a new registered nurse i just
graduated in december congratulations
man
thank you i appreciate that the only
debt that i have
is something that i did pretty dumb
about a month ago
i purchased a new truck
so it's about twenty four thousand
dollars in debt okay
now i wanna go back to grad school in
like two to three years
to be a anesthesiologist and the average
cost
of the entire three-year program is
about 130 000
depending on what school you go to
so i've been having some like buyers
regret and i wanted to
get someone's opinion like do i sell the
truck and focus on saving for school
or do i just pay off the truck first and
then go from there i didn't know if i
if i sold the truck if i needed to treat
the future debt like how i would in baby
step two and just focus on
you know saving up all that money for
school how much is the truck worth
so the truck is worth i'd say
19 000. the extra like four or five
grand was for like the maintenance and
the warranty and stuff how much do you
make right now
so i make uh every month
i make i would say 1700 uh i'm sorry
man you're nursing at the wrong place
yeah 3 500
a month and how old are you i'm 24.
okay yeah i mean get rid of the truck
you know but you got to have something
you got to have something to uh to drive
i'm guessing or are you in a situation
where you could
use public transportation to get to your
job i have no idea what boise idaho is
looking like and where you're at
what are your transportation needs yeah
i'd probably have to buy a car i have
about like four
four thousand five thousand dollars
saved up yeah let me tell you something
i want you this is what i want you to do
tonight before you go to bed i want you
to go on autotrader.com or find other
cars.com i don't care i'm not endorsing
any website i'm just telling you go
go to one of those websites and just and
just put in your budget
and see what's out there i think it's
going to blow your mind of how much
quality something that will get you a
and b and it doesn't look like you know
rats have been living in it um and i
think that's what you do
and you get this debt out of your life
and now you're back to square one when
you're debt
free and then i'd get after i'd get
after it i'd work i'd take as much
overtime i don't know what the options
are for you as a nurse there but
you know you want to save up and cash
flow your way through this the other
thing i want to challenge you on
is you said on average the schooling you
want to do is 130
000. what's the low end on that
like a hundred i'd go 100.
and let me tell you why nobody
i mean nobody roberto cares where you
went to school
take the cheapest option if it's viable
take the cheapest option don't go don't
go average
go the lowest cost possible and i would
delay it
i i'd work my tail off and i'd delay it
until i have it all in the bank
because it's just not going to be worth
it i promise you
and roberto i want you to hear what
you're saying the next three years
right you're 24 years old you're playing
a 30 year old game
as a 24 year old you're gonna work every
weekend
you're gonna work every night you're
gonna stack that money and stack it and
stack it and stack it
and then you're gonna go pay cash and
you along the way
you're gonna develop a reputation as a
great nurse
i was going to say killer nurse and that
had a bad connotation yeah you're going
to be
recognized as a great nurse you're going
to get some
extraordinary experiences because
there's difference of working the night
shift as the morning shift
you know that and then you're going to
be ready to
exhale and go to a graduate program get
your feet underneath you you're going to
pay cash and you're going to come out as
a 28 29 year old
making a jillion dollars as a nurse
anesthesiologist
and you're going to have no debt and
then it's going to be game on brother
and listen don't just hear what john
said i want you to feel the truth behind
what john said
because when you do that he just gave
you a beautiful fast forward into the
future
and when you come out that way there's
going to be other people in that
anesthesia program that are just crushed
by
debt and every nickel they're making is
going just to keep their nose above
water i want you to
feel that future i want you to feel the
difference
if you can if you can place yourself in
where your
other uh fellow students will be versus
where john placed you
that will keep you from being tempted
i'm telling you
the degree is there the anesthesiology
jobs are there the money are there but
please
please please do it the right way here's
a picture what that looks like
as i was a dean of students of a law
school and then i went back to get a
second
degree i drove an old corolla like an 01
or a 2000 corolla because i was going to
put my money over here versus over there
didn't make me any better than anybody
else did anything like that
and man my buddies gave me a hard time
my my friends and colleagues and they
should have right i looked ridiculous
but it was an internal decision i want
this more than this right
and so i want him to know man you can
keep pulling into that same hospital
parking lot over the next two three four
years
in a used honda or a used whatever
you're not gonna press anybody that's
not your goal right now your goal is a
debt free walking across that graduation
stage
as an anesthesiologist a nurse
anesthesiologist owing nobody
anything and then then brother the world
is yours
right yeah now you're talking about
stacking money and anywhere in the
country
right you could go anywhere with that
degree yep
you know i want i want to stay here
because i think this is such a
it's such a temptation and it's such a
it's a mental mountain for people to get
over an emotional mountain to get over
let's play this out so if if somebody
does it the way
everybody else if roberto does it the
way everybody else does it he's not
going to he's already told us that
you come out and you're so burdened by
debt
and you realize that okay i got the
degree i got the job i'm making good
money but i'm not
tasting the fruits of that i'm not
seeing the fruit of that i
i know i'm making it but it's
disappearing
and then all of a sudden the resentment
and frustration begin to build
and it becomes toxic and then they call
it ken coleman show john they go
i'm burned out i don't i don't i don't i
gotta i gotta find a new career
and i go what and we dive into it we
find out no you don't
you're just miserable you're resenting
yourself you're resenting the job
because you're having to work crazy
hours
and you don't find yourself getting
ahead and you go did i make the wrong
decision
you didn't make the wrong decision on
the work is what i find most of the time
you made the wrong decision financially
and then you just never get hit
versus holding off here and he comes out
and goes man i'm doing the work i love
i'm in my sweet spot but boy oh boy i'm
also
like in high school when we were getting
in shape we had to pull tires
yeah right you sprint you're pulling
that tire behind you and man you sure
can run fast when
you're in a game when you don't have a
tire behind you right not the truth and
that's debt right you can run anywhere
you want
to yeah it's awesome so you got to be
careful
it's such a great exercise john to get
out there in front of it and go wait a
second what's the desired future
if i don't do the debt what's the future
look like
if i am straddled you know or saddled
rather with debt you know and
because well here's his life he's got a
24 000 truck
he's gonna go to work in a high stress
high yes a secondary traumatic stress
gig is hard
his buddies are going to want to get off
shift and go hang out go eat go hang out
go eat
he's going to meet somebody they're
going to bring dead into that
relationship too
and then they're going to need to buy a
house and then he's going to want to go
to grad school
and then suddenly you're going to look
up and like you mentioned you're going
to be living life underwater yeah
as opposed to just biting down on your
mouthpiece for a couple of years going
in there swinging
and you turn around 26 27 years old yeah
man you set your you set your entire
legacy up
and it's so frustrating ken and it's so
hard i know here's here's
what i found just about anybody says i'm
willing to do what it takes
you betcha but then you say are you
willing to wait as long as it takes
whoa hold on that's good everybody's
willing to do what it takes very few are
willing to wait
as long as it takes that's the
difference patience
is the magic you got to have it hey i
want to thank my colleague
dr john deloney always fun to be with
you pal want to thank our producer ben
hill i want to thank kelly daniel our
associate producer and i want to thank
you america
thank you for joining us this is your
show this is the ramsay show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts